hey guys what's up this is andrew or
jensens.com so as you can see i don't
have a facecam for this video because
you know i'm in istanbul still have my
flight
tonight guys and i'm taking some time
for you to make an update on gmu because
it's been long time i didn't do it
and in istanbul even if i'm in a good
hotel
uh the wi-fi is [ __ ] guys so i can't
basically uh send my face facecam
videos to be edited so anyways i'm gonna
be like
this for this one so let's analyze what
happened on gamestop last week and see
what are the different scenarios for the
coming week
let's get into it
all right guys so as usual i'm gonna
start by reminding you what i was saying
in my last video so i was telling you
that here we have uh some kind of a
complex correction i was here
you know using a triangle because i like
to see triangles in
those last corrective patterns uh
actually the triangle broke
and we went to the 175 area
which for me is still okay because you
know i told you
i measured the first wave i checked the
fib
retracement levels and the 180 level 79
level is for me the level
below which i don't feel comfortable at
all for a second wave so for now this
scenario is still on the table the one
two is still on the table
because the second wave retracement is
higher than 78.6 usually it goes to 50
or 61.8 alright those are the typical
retracement level
but once again let me remind you guys
how it happened for amc
and so i'm doing an amc video as well
here for example
after the first wave the breakout level
we had
that is here you know so basically i'm
taking this one because this move
really is what gamestop is doing right
now guys all right
look gamestop is just breaking out from
the larger degree counting all right so
when i take the two highs here
and i connect them i come up with the
stuff all right guys
you can see and here we broke the 100
and
the 200 level roughly we have retested
it we broke i'm gonna come back to this
very soon that's
not looking nice i agree but it's still
fine for me we broke the 200 level
and just to remind you guys that amc
after this
first wave even if the first wave was
you know a bit
shorter than the gamestop first wave
let's measure that
this so the first wave of amc took forty
percent
the one of them stopped yeah a hundred
percent all right
so 130 percent so you can see that the
first wave of your stop is much much
stronger so maybe we're gonna have even
stronger third wave let's see
but here we came back to the 78.6
retracement level as well before
starting the third wave
so it is fine for me what else i wanted
to show you
i have here because the question we all
having
is that is this actually bearish or not
and to me this is bullish guys because
once again i'm gonna explain in this
video
why to me this correction is
totally healthy i told you guys by the
way let me remind you what i was saying
you know a long time ago i was here
telling you all the way up
that we're gonna break 200 that this is
looking very good we're doing a
beautiful one two three four five
and then i was telling you that we're
gonna correct to the 220 area
actually we went even to the 200 level
and we broke it all right
so you know this stuff happens look for
example what we had
here okay does it look familiar guys
does it look familiar yeah after some
strong moves down
we like to have this kind of you know
consolidations that
just move sideways this is what we're
having here and usually in this kind of
stuff
you have those uh bullish divergences
regular bullish dividends so here you
can see
the max is going higher so the momentum
is coming back and the market is making
new lows
all right so basically the bears can't
uh take
more ground here i mean they take more
ground but with the momentum shifting up
all right so it's this divergence the
regular bullish divergence
the market is going lower but with the
momentum shifting
back already so it's usually a sign of a
reversal so the reversal doesn't need to
come right away guys it can come after
you know one week two weeks you know
sometimes it takes time how long have
how have we been stuck here it's been
one month guys we're here one month
we're in this conciliation
so it might take maybe one or two more
weeks i don't know to answer that
question
what i like to do is try to label this
using elliot wave theory
and here as you guys saw i'm you know
showing you guys this all the time but
you know for those who are watching my
video for
the first time it's very interesting
that you guys have a look at that
double and triple three so this is
elliott wave book
okay i'll just type elliott theory on
google frost and presta
the writers and you can see that the
typical corrective patterns that move
sideways are you know
a flat for example a zigzag and a
triangle you know a flat
zigzag zigzag you know stuff like this
and this is exactly what we're having
here
zigzag very sharp then here zigzag and
here you can put a zigzag maybe it's
going to be a triangle you know it's
very very hard to guess so i can try to
guess guys but to be honest i have no
clue
what kind of corrective pattern we're
going to have usually we're having
triangles in uh last waves all right so
it's here
although up on extremely rare occasions
a second wave in
an impulse appears to take the form of a
triangle triangles nearly
always occur in position prior to the
final actionary wave in the pattern of
one larger degree
so whenever you see a triangle guys you
know if you're sure it's a triangle
then usually it means that this is the
last corrective pattern
of a larger degree wave counting so
that's why here i'm always spotting if i
don't have a triangle here
i don't see a triangle for now but you
know you can always find some if you you
know for example
a b c d e it can be an expanding
triangle all right
but then here i'm missing a x so if this
happens it would be actually here
and then the b wave would be here c wave
like this okay
but here guys i'm just doing some
guessings and
you know to me it's better to try to see
where what is the momentum doing and
what kind uh who is in control
and here definitely we are in a bearish
correction but once again when you
cannot find something clean
in your counting like i did here guys
how clean is that for you how clean is
that it's perfect all right
when you find something that perfect
that clean you know that the trend
is up right we're going higher here
we're just correcting
so my scenario is not changing i still
believe
we're gonna do a three four five and go
to the 800 area
i don't know when guys i know it's been
a long time i'm saying that
but this is what my tools are giving to
me
so i think that this would eventually
happen then i need to tell you that
if we break the 170 level
what is here then my one two is less
likely to happen all right this one too
because the second waves usually don't
correct below the 78.6 percent it can
happen of course everything can happen
this is finance this is training guys
this is only about probabilities
but usually it doesn't happen so if it
happens very carefully
and here i also have you know i like to
use signals
that actually come from different
methods and here if i connect
the lower level here with the lower
lower level here
my two lows i have a trend line which
level is around 170 area so roughly the
same area
so the 170 is the level below which guys
i don't feel good if we break 170 let me
tell you what would happen guys the
bears would definitely be in control
and they would probably push for the 135
level before pushing for 110 level so
this is the bearish case but once again
guys
this doesn't look like it at all because
we're having those
uh bullish divergences here all right so
basically this is very weak
and you know we making new lows but with
the momentum shifting
higher all right as you can see here
guys this is the macd
blue line and it's shifting higher so
yeah
to some of the situation guys i'm still
bullish
above the 170 level i feel very good i'm
just trying to label the correct pattern
that is happening
i see some regular bullish divergences
so it's telling me that
the bears are weak even if we are in a
bearish corrective pattern
and i believe that you know the third
wave might come maybe in one week maybe
maybe this week maybe next week i don't
know when you know let's be honest but
i believe it's gonna finally come so
let's be patient and let's see what is
happening that's it for me guys
i hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys